I'm actually scared for this one really
yeah now I'm scared
we're gonna be eating some weird snacks
weird snack combinations I'm not exactly
sure what weird snacks entails
I'm just like hoping it's not like some
sort of animal parts I don't want to
Fear Factor up in here yeah weird
combinations do freak me out so if
there's like Oreos with ketchup or
something that's disrespectful
anything's up yeah
for grabs let's see let's see oh oh
great
but with ranch I love grapes
I love ranch you ever have them together
I actually think I have you go first let
me put a lot of French I'd go for a
little ranch
cheers Cheers
hmmm that's fun no good you know it
remind the texture reminds me of like
when you dip celery maybe this is like a
parent trying to get their child to eat
more fruits yeah and this is working for
me I feel like you know when you buy
those platters from the store of the
vegetables and you have the ranch in the
middle like someone accidentally put
grapes in there the first time when I
tried grates with ranch was because I
went to a party there was a veggie
platter
in a fruit platter grates we're touching
the ranch didn't I'm not a food waster
so I put it in my mouth anyway it was
fine I enjoyed it I would not eat this
again I would really really not eat this
again
not this again I would eat it again I'm
in the mirror but more linked to the not
one thumbs up as would be enjoy Oreos
they enjoy orange juice I love dipping
Oreo in milk alright let's do this do we
let it get soggy um I'm going full-tilt
I'm making an extra soggy okay it's all
bad mm-hmm really good I kind of like
this like you get the first hit of the
Oreo and then you get a little after
citrusy taste mm-hmm it makes the
vanilla cream inside like an orange
cream so it's a creamsicle yeah Oreo
creamsicle yeah oh damn mmm somebody did
this because they ran out of milk maybe
they were trying to eat Oreos with milk
and then they realized they ran out of
milk and the only other beverage they
had was water and orange juice it's
something I wouldn't have thought of but
now that I'm eating it it makes sense I
still like the classic dip in milk hell
yeah I'm having this all the time now
I'm gonna push this on my friends I
don't give this a thumbs up thumbs up
for this guy
I say thumbs up for this appearing
oh no oh no oh no maybe like cereal okay
this one I'm a little upset about I
think the only thing that's like nice
about this combo is because like when
you a lot of spicy food milk kinda helps
of the spice yeah so maybe that's why
it's not too late to change anything
right now this is some you just lost a
dare kind of stuff yes
what's a good analogy for this death I
hate to be a weirdo but I like this too
this isn't as bad as I thought it was
gonna be almost anus tasted like a cold
soup after the cheeto dust kind of
dissipates into the milk it kind of just
hit site cornflakes and milk
I've never pictured the phrase once the
cheeto dust melts into the milk before
but like it feels so wrong but you like
it but I like it
why see milk is not bad don't knock it
till you try it I would eat this in an
extreme occasion I would eat it in like
a not as extreme occasion I would try
this again with friends just to see
their reaction and see what they think
of aside some creeping towards and up
though yeah it definitely thumbs up just
one thumbs up yeah
are you Orion Oh Jay is literally ur
winner the best one was Oreos and orange
juice
spicy milk first second one was grapes
and ranch for you it's the she doesn't
know second place would be Oreo and
orange juice third that's hot she
doesn't milk yes I agree
grape with ranch their grapes and the
Cheetos are both last place for me I
thought they were gonna be real nasty
yeah that was like that was pretty
pleasant I would dine with you again I
would say I'm too nice to leave a
negative review on Yelp so I just ignore
it and never come back
[Music]
[Music]